معنا من مخيم قلنديا شمال القدس مراسل
الجزيره حسام مسعود حسام مرحبا بك معنا
والمخيم اذا يشهد توغلات ووجود اليات
عسكريه اسرائيليه ضعنا في
الصوره تماما مخيم قلنديا في هذه اللحظات
يشهد اقتحاما واسعا من قبل قوات الاحتلال
التي تتمركز هنا عند مدخل المخيم وكذلك
تنتشر في داخل المخيم في هذه اللحظات
تتراجع هذه الاليه بينما يلقى الحجاره
تلقى الحجاره في هذه اللحظات باتجاه
الاليه
وكما تشهد اليات الاحتلال ايضا تصديا من
قبل الشبان الفلسطينيين لهذا الاقتحام هذه
الاليه تتمركز عند مدخل المخيم
لتمنع المواطنين الفلسطينيين من الدخول
الى المخيم في اطار عمليه عسكريه تشمل عده
اليات قامت باقتحام ال المخيم وهي في هذه
الاثناء تقوم بتنفيذ عمليات مداهمه لمنازل
الفلسطينيين في داخل المخيم كما تشاهدون
الحجاره ما زالت تلقى على هذه الاليه وهو
الامر الذي ايضا حدث في داخل المخيم في ظل
تصدر من قبل المواطنين الفلسطينيين لقوات
الاحتلال التي تقدم مخيم قليا في هذه
اللحظ ظات في اطار
قيام قوات قوات الاحتلال في تنفيذ عمليات
اعتقال ومداهم وتفتيش للمنازل وهو الامر
ايضا الذي حدث في عدد من المحافظات
الفلسطينيه في هذه الاثناء في ظل قيام
واستمرار قوات الاحتلال بتنفيذ عمليات
الاقتحام المتكرره
والمتواصل لمناطق ومدن الضفه الغربيه
ومخيماتها المختلفه هذه الاقتحامات
شملت مختلف انحاء الضفه الغربيه خلال هذه
الليله في كل من جنين وتحديدا في مدينه
جبع او بلده جبع وكذلك في مدينه نابلس
ومخيم عسكر الجديد وكذلك عسكر البلد
وانسحبت قوات الاحتلال قبل قليل فقط من
مدينه نابلس بعد اقتحامها فيما ايضا قامت
باقتحام
بلده ايضا او عفوا محافظه طولكرم وكذلك
مدينه قلقيليه وايضا بلده بيت فجار في
جنوب الضفه الغربيه وتحديدا في محافظه بيت
لحم في اطار استمرار هذه الاقتحامات
المتواصله ل الضفه الغربيه كما تشاهدون
هذه الاليه التي تقف في هذه المنطقه
هي تقوم بمفاجاه الماره من هذا الشارع هذه
الاليه كانت تغلق الشارع لكنها تراجعت الى
مدخل المخيم وهو هو ما يفاجئ الماره
السيارات التي تمر في هذا المكان هي لا
تعلم بوجود الاليه وهو ما يشكل خطرا على
السكان المواطنين الذين يمرون عبر هذا
الطريق الاساسي الواصل ما بين جنوب الضفه
الغربيه مرورا برم الله ووصولا الى شمال
الضفه الغربيه ويضاف الى هذه الاليه ايضا
وجود اليات في داخل المخيم ايضا كما
تشاهدون وهي في اطار هذا الانتشار الواسع
لاليات قوات الاحتلال في مخيم قلنديا
التصدي من قبل قوات الاحتلال او عفوا
التصدي من قبل الشبان لاليات قوات
الاحتلال في هذه المنطقه كما تشاهدون
وربما تلاحظون معنا هطول و تراشق الحجاره
من قبل الشبان وهو الاسلوب المتبع هنا في
قلنديا
في عبر قيام الشبان بالتصدي عبر هذه
الوسيله البسيطه فقط وليس كما يشهد مخ او
تشهد مخيمات اخرى كما جرى في مخيم عسكر
على سبيل المثال
اشتباكات مسلحه واسعه ل مع قوات الاحتلال
في اطاري وخلال هذه الاقتحامات التي
شهدتها المحافظات المختلفه قبل قليل قوات
الاحتلال قامت بالقاء قنابل الغاز المسيل
للدموع لتفريق عدد من الشبان الذين تصدوا
لهذا الاقتحام ولكن حتى هذه اللحظه ما
زالت العمليه العسكريه في داخل مخيم
قلنديا مستمره في اطار هذا الاقتحام
المتواصل قبل نصف ساعه فقط وصلت هذه
الاليات الى مدخل المخيم و هو ما ادى الى
استمرار هذا الاقتحام حتى هذه اللحظه
ويمكن ان تتطور الاوضاع في مخيم قلنديا مع
استمرار هذا الاقتحام في حال ط وقت هذا
الاقتحام وهو الامر الذي كنا قد لاحظناه
وتابعنا في اقتحامات سابقه نفذتها قوات
الاحتلال وجيش الاحتلال خلال الايام
الماضيه
وخلال الاقتحامات السابقه وهي التي تكررت
بشكل واضح خلال الفتره الماضيه نستطيع
مشاهده جنود الاحتلال في هذه اللحظه وهم
يتقدمون في شوارع المخيم ويعودون من داخل
المخيم الى هذه الاليه تحديدا
هذه المشاهد التي نتابعها في هذه الاثناء
تظهر بشكل واضح اليات الاحتلال وكذلك جنود
الاحتلال الذين نعم نعم يحضرون معهم
المعتقلين في هذه اللحظات والذين قاموا
باعتقالهم من داخل
المخيم
وهذا
المشهد يشير الى واقع ونموذج عن واقع
الاقتحامات التي تنفذها قوات الاحتلال
والتي تقوم خلالها
باعتقال الفلسطينيين من منازلهم خلال
الليل هذا هذا المشهد تحديدا الذي نراه
الان يظهر اعتقال عدد من الشبان القوات
الان هي في حاله استنفار كامل كما
تشاهدون وجيش الاحتلال سيقوم بنقل الشبان
الذين قام باعتقالهم من داخل مخيم قرن
عبر الياته ويقوم باخراجهم من هذا المكان
نستطيع مشاهده هذا الشاب الذي توقفه قوات
الاحتلال في هذه
الاثناء هو احد الشبان الذين اعتقلتهم من
داخل المخيم في اطار عمليتها العسكريه ما
زالت هذه العمليه العسكريه
متواصله نستطيع مشاهده حاله الاستنفار
التي تشهدها هذه المنطقه الان في ظل قيام
قوات الاحتلال
باستمرار
ومواصله
اعتقالها لهذا الشاب عند مدخل المخيم حاله
من الاستنفار لتصدي لاي محاوله للاشتباك
وتصدي مع القوات الا تقف في هذا المكان
ندي زيا اسرائيليا او انه انها
تتخذه درعا بشريا يعني لا نستطيع ان نميز
حتى اللحظه ما ما الذي يرتد نعم من
الممكن نعم محمد بالفعل المشهد غريب قوات
الاحتلال تعتقل هذا الشاب الذي يرتدي ستره
واقيه كما نشاهد في هذه اللحظات وزيا يشبه
الزيه العسكري وايضا يضع على راسه ما يشبه
ايضا الخوذه لا نستطيع ان نحدد ما اذا
كانت قوات الاحتلال هي التي البسته هذا
الزي وهي تستخدمه درعا بشريا كما ذكرت ام
انها تقوم في هذه الاثناء باعتقاله لكنه
موقوف وهو مكبل بالسلاسل الحديديه هذا ما
نستطيع رصده ونستطيع ايضا مشاهده حاله
الاستنفار المتواصله لقوات الاحتلال في
محاوله لرصد اي محاوله للاشتباك مع قوات
الاحتلال نتيجه للخطر الشديد الذي يمكن ان
يحدث في
حال بدء اشتباك من قبل ال المقاومين
الفلسطينيين الموجودون او الموجودين في
محيط مخيم قلنديا والذين يمكن ان يشتبكوا
مع قوات الاحير اثناء انسحابها وهو ما
يمكن ان يفسر حاله استخدام هذا الشاب كدرع
بشري كما ذكرت محمد في حاله تاكد ذلك وا
هي محاوله من قبل قوات الاحتلال لتجنب
اطلاق النار عليها اثناء انسحابها او
اثناء
تحركها من مخيم قلنديا في هذه الاثناء
وبينما نشاهد هذا المشهد في هذه اللحظات
توقيف هذا الشاب وضعه امام الجنود وا
الوقوف خلف هذا الشاب في محاوله لاستخدامه
كدرع بشري ايضا تستمر العمليه العسكريه في
داخل مخيم قلنديا ويستمر الاقتحام وما
يشمل هذا الاقتحام من مداهمات للمنازل
وام محاولات لقوات الاحتلال
لاعتقال الفلسطينيين لا سما الذين تصفهم
بالمطلوبين من داخل المخيم الانتشار
انتشار جنود الاحتلال مازال متواصلا في
داخل المخيم كما عند مدخل المخيم كما
نشاهد وما زالت هذه الاليه موجوده واليات
اخرى ايضا نستطيع ان نراها بالعين المجرده
ايضا في عمق
الشارع الرئيسي المؤدي الى داخل المخيم
مازلنا نشاهد ايضا الان يتخذ هذا الجندي
وعيه وضعيه قتاليه
وهو يحاول ان يرصد مدخل المخيم ما اذا كان
هناك اي نوع من انواع الاشتباك او ما اذا
كان هناك مقاومين عند مدخل المخيم ولكن ال
كما ذكرنا المقاومه مقاومه هذه الاليات
كانت عبر القاء الحجاره فقط وهي الوسيله
التقليديه للشعب الفلسطيني للشبان
الفلسطينيين في التعامل مع جنود واليات
الاحتلال في هذا
الاقتحام تحديدا فيما كان كما ذكرنا سابقا
مخيم قلنديا قد شهد سابقا مواجهات عسكريه
مع جنود الاحتلال يقتاد الجنود الان مجددا
هذا الشاب كما
نشاهد يقوم الجنود باقتياد
مجددا
و يتراجعون قليلا ثم ايضا يعودون معه وهو
ما يشير مجددا ويؤكد محمد ان هذا الشاب
يتم استخدامه الان كدرع بشري من قبل جنود
الاحتلال وهذا ياتي في اطار استمرار
اقتحامها كما كما نشاهد الان هذا الشاب ما
زال يستخدم حتى هذه اللحظه كدرع بشري ولا
نعلم اذا كان هذا الشاب هو معتقل سيجري
اعتقاله ونقله من داخل مخيم قلنديا عبر
الاليات العسكريه ام انه س يترك بحال
سبيله بعد انتهاء العمليه العسكريه وان ما
كان الجنود يقومون به هو فقط استخدام هذا
الشاب المكبل بالسلاسل الحديديه كدرع بشري
فقط وهو وهنا تجدر الاشاره الى ان هذا
النوع من استخدام الشبان الفلسطينيين كدرع
بشري هو كان قد تكرر عده مرات خلال
اقتحامات قوات الاحتلال في مختلف انحاء
الضفه الغربيه في مختلف المخيمات والمدن
والبلدات كانت قوات الاحتلال قد استخدمت
هذه
الوسيله قيام الجنود باستخدام شبان
مواطنين فلسطينيين كدرع بشري للاحتماء خلف
هؤلاء الشبان
لعلم الجنود جنود الاحتلال ان المقاومين
الفلسطينيين لن يطلقوا النار على جنود
الاحتلال في حال قاموا باستخدام فلسطينيين
اخرين كدرع بشري وهو ما كنا قد رصدناه في
عده حالات سابقه من بينها حالات استخدم ما
فيها جيش الاحتلال دروع بشريه على الياته
ايضا لمنع ايضا اطلاق النار او القنابل
محليه الصنع على الياته خلال الاقتحام اذا
نعود ونؤكد ان مخيم قلنديا مازال يشهد في
هذه اللحظات استمرارا للعمليه العسكريه
واستمرارا ل الاقتحام والمداهمات
والاعتقالات في هذه اللحظه طبعا في متابعه
هذا الاقتحام حسن مسعود من مخيم لديا شكرا
جزيلا
لك